my name is Simon Martin marlborough I
work as a member that the accounts along
inform societics where we are actually
addressing very important issues she
proposed to national governments all
around the world this is if these issues
could be divided into three different
blocks first of all from a production
point of view we are worried and we are
trying to deliver a new way and seeing
ethical standards not only within
digital newsrooms but also in the way
that readers are becoming almost
professional writers that dialogue
between reporters editors and readers
but link there is space work to study
and to explore in terms of accuracy in
terms of independent information in
terms of filtering data sources from a
consumption point of view we are also
addressing a key element or for all ages
and all fields of knowledge which is
media literacy through education systems
none of this makes sense there is not a
perfect framework a perfect framework
and a social environment that makes
transparency and respect to basic
elements among all ages